I see you soon I love that guy final
destination five alright it's really
funny about final destination movies I
think you can watch my review of the
final destination or final destination
for whatever I sit in there probably
applies to this movie but in final
destination 5 there's going to be a big
disaster it's a bridge this time that
collapses one generic kid gets a vision
of the whole thing he tells everyone to
scram off the bridge the ones who get
off the bridge they live everyone else
dies and now that's coming for you but
as for final destination 5 once again
death is pissed off that he's been
cheated out of 8 Souls and I was
sequentially killing them off in
glorious Manor and let's face it this
movie exists for one thing the deaths
which I'm not gonna lie in terms of
final destination 5 if I were to work on
this movie or something there are two
jobs I would want one the guy who has to
think up all the weird-ass mousetrap
style deaths that is a guy with
imagination right there probably a
pretty fun job too and admit it you
think of that [ __ ] too and the casting
director I think the casting director in
this movie has the easiest job ever
because here's how you cast a final
destination movie you take the names of
all the hopeful waiters in LA put them
all in a hat draw eight names out you
now have your cast for final destination
done see you soon other than the boss
from waiting in that guy from you know
hundred other comedies the most
recognizable face in this movie it's not
even his face you recognize he looks
like a young Tom Cruise impersonator
that's why you recognized yeah not Tom
Cruise Tom Cruise impersonator no as for
the deaths in this movie some of them
are really cool some of them are some of
them just kind of fell short there were
a couple that had really good build up
and then in the end gravity killed him I
mean at first it was like okay it's
starting to get elaborate and in the end
it was just a fall cuz nothing beats the
second one logged through the face is
beautiful I'm feeling pretty morbid
right now but it's probably my favorite
final destination death as for the 3d it
was garbage I didn't think the 3d look
good at all the depth of field was crap
it was blurring some scenes it just no
it had a lot of 3d gimmicks of course
like pulls dough into people's bodies no
you know it's doing that whole thing
where it pops out at you that being said
the 3d still looks like crap because I
am done with the whole movie theater
gimmick at this point the moment I saw
4d rhumba scope done and when I was
watching the movie I was like they
should just make a montage which is all
the deaths and final destination sure
enough end credits come montage of all
the deaths from the other four movies
made my day coolest part of the movie
right there it's like I felt the love
from the movie at that point it was like
Valentine's Day so it has the acting you
expect it has the people you expect it
has the hot chicks you expect it has the
desk
kind of expect but you kind of get
disappointed also some are really cool
so I'm disappointing in the end this
movie will probably be a good time when
you're drunk yeah Naza party I can't
feel my face I say when not if cuz you
know you're gonna go into this movie
hammered but be respectful to your movie
theater crew and don't puke in the
aisles so what is your favorite movie
death in any movie ever
not just final destination but any movie
ever you can do final destination in any
movie ever if you want for me it's got
to be Jason axe shitty movie awesome
death there's a sink of liquid nitrogen
Jason takes the girl's head and puts her
head in the liquid nitrogen and the
cameras looking up from the bottom of
the sink and you see her just screaming
in her face freezes he just pulls her
head out and smashes on the counter cool
is death ever whatever it is comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more